[Music]
next question
okay this one comes from aj again how do
we explain colossians two verses and we
get someone from someone who's not had a
question if you say aj again we've had
one from him can we get one from someone
else who has not asked the question
all right so this next one comes from sp
i'm asking for someone else
is it okay for a female to wear weave if
she is losing her hair
okay
uh
where are we if she's losing her hair
loss of hair for male or female is
always undesirable but is catastrophic
for a female
to lose their hair very very damaging
i
uh what do i say to that
i can't find a text that says you can't
do it
and i cannot call to mind a quotation
from the spiritual prophecy that
condemns it
there's a fundamental principle in all
things there's a glory of god
if the person applies that and has a
clear conscience i have no authority to
tell that person don't wear a weave or
two weaves
um so if it's for the glory of god why
are you doing it
now
you know if someone has if i am missing
one of my eyes i know without glasses to
keep you know the thing from being seen
and so
the lord is a very compassionate god he
understands our feelings he enters into
our feelings with us because he knows
we're flesh he knows that he's not hard
and stern and sometimes we present him
or maybe i do that sometimes he's
understanding when
when he told go to the mountain lot said
let me go to the city and god said okay
you know it wasn't my idea god said okay
everyone said oh how great the mercy of
god did his children god said go to the
mountain lord said let me go to the city
god said okay okay okay go but god still
loved him and god protected him and so
if you know if i were a woman then i
would lose in my hair oh i'd find some
way to cover it up
look at men men do all sorts of things
to cover up their hair when they're
losing hair and so i don't see the sin
in it i just don't know if we're
entering something elaborate the size of
an eagle's nest now we have another
problem you understand what i'm trying
to say we have another problem since 10
feet long rolling all over the ground
i'm not talking about that i mean a
simple cosmetic intervention you know to
preserve your sense of self because how
we look affects our sense of self i have
no problem with that but i have no bible
verse four against it i have no egypti
quotations for against it but i would
not condemn
you if i have a gap right here
something's missing i put in something
fill it out
are you sending me to hell for that no
no i'm not going
no i don't see the sin i don't see the
sin so sister god bless you yeah i'm
sorry about the loss
and may god bless your efforts god can
restore hair he can if he wants to he
raised lazarus he can rest very hears if
he had a number pray to god change your
diet you know do something dietary see
what results you can get
next question
[Music]